je vais recevoir
cet organisme et
le mois dernier à l'occasion du 40e
anniversaire de la fondation et
de la pointe artiste aux multiples
chapeaux Jean Lapointe à consacrer
beaucoup d'énergie pendant une bonne
partie de sa vie à lutter contre les
dépendances avec nous maître André
champagne qui a présidé le conseil
d'administration de la Fondation Jean
Lapointe en plus d'avoir été impliqué
plus de 30 ans dans la maison dans la
pointe bonjour monsieur champagne
merci de prendre le temps d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
ça me fait plaisir madame je dois bien
ça
vous le connaissiez vous le connaissiez
depuis longtemps racontez-nous qu'est-ce
que vous allez retenir de lui vous
je vais retenir surtout dans le fond
tout à l'heure je pensais à ça qu'est-ce
que je vais retenir le plus
je vais retenir le plus
à ma connaissance il y a dû sauver la
vie
d'un minimum ce matin que tu leur as
pensé un minimum de 5 personnes 5
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui des
hommes à succès
sans à la pointe ils étaient dans la
mayonnaise quand je vous dis le des
hommes à grands succès
qui finissaient 40 ans de boissons par
jour
dont je l'entête il a pris le téléphone
il était même en état d'esprit
il y a téléphoné à maison dans la pointe
il a réussi à avoir le numéro de
téléphone de Jean il a appelé Jean il
dit j'arrive où es-tu
étant donné le rencontrer dans un bar
il est sorti du bord il est devenu son
parrain
et aujourd'hui cet homme-là qui est papy
comme je le suis que des enfants
évidemment un homme à succès
sans gens là convaincu le aujourd'hui je
pourrais même pas vous en parler de ce
monsieur
c'est une implication directe ça c'est
lui qui a vraiment fait un changement
mais ça fondation sa maison a aidé
encore beaucoup plus de gens ça a
vraiment eu un gros rayonnement
la maison ça a commencé avec la maison
Kerb parce que Jean a été à la maison
Kern en tant que patient
un moment donné les années ont passé
puis il y a décidé lui d'ouvrir d'une
maison il y a peut-être il était arrangé
pour que la maison Kerb devienne la
Maison Jean Lapointe
c'est devenu la Maison Jean Lapointe et
après ça ça prenne une fondation parce
que comme vous savez pour aller chercher
des sous c'est plus facile lorsque tu as
une fondation que si tu dis je mets une
maison je vais chercher de l'argent etc
donc qui a formé la Fondation Jean
Lapointe après ça c'est impliqué
tellement savez-vous qu'est-ce qu'a fait
il y avait des téléthons à ce moment-là
tu as permis les téléthons il y avait
des téléthons c'est lui qui organisait
les téléthons puis aller chercher des
des meilleurs des meilleurs acteurs et
les meilleurs chanteurs
Fernand etc
pour venir par un spectacle et ça
travaillait 24 heures sur 24 et aller
chercher beaucoup de sous un moment
donné les téléthons tombés comme vous le
savez et là c'est là qui m'a demandé de
prendre la présidence de la Fondation
puis il me dit André mais sans que ça
serait bon si notre œuvre s'orientait un
peu plus vers les jeunes plutôt que vers
les gens de 50 ans qui prennent un verre
donc ils disent qu'on va faire pense à
quelque chose qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire parce qu'on a commencé à
s'impliquer beaucoup puis on a dirigé la
Fondation vers la prévention dans les
écoles puis aujourd'hui la Fondation
depuis 8 ans va chercher des sous les
donne à la maison puis la maison fait de
la prévention dans les écoles avec les
enfants de 13 ans 14 ans secondaire 1 2
et 3 puis après ça si vous savez ce que
c'est des jeunes à 4,5 c'est plus
difficile donc les quatre cinq ils
deviennent les parrains les les
meilleurs de secondaire 3 et qui
finissent les plus aidés les plus vieux
les causes au cours des années est-ce
que c'est un grand mobilisation en fait
que un entrepreneur social est-ce que
c'est comme ça que vous le voyez écoutez
la famille moi je l'ai connu
j'avais 23 ans
la pointe là je l'ai connu à cause de
ces de son frère Jean Gabriel Lapointe
qui était un des meilleurs avocat du
Canada je l'ai connu à cause de son
autre frère Sam c'est lui qui a dessiné
le métro de Montréal son frère les trois
frères la pointe et les soeurs en plus
ça c'est une famille exceptionnelle des
mauvaises
le film de Duplessis etc mais le
souvenir que j'ai c'est qu'il va avoir
clairement clairement pour moi sauver
des gens directement que je connais qui
lui ont encore puis la maison continue
des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes c'est un très bel héritage qui
laisse merci beaucoup maître champagne
d'avoir été avec nous
sympathie à toute la famille d'ailleurs
placé un appel à Jean-Marie
merci beaucoup madame bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI